some of the criticism that we've gotten
like slate did a piece about us and a
couple other publications have written
pieces like this where they say here's
the reason the babylon b's not funny
they're not funny because
they're
rather than having their jokes tethered
to the truth or reality their jokes are
riding on the back of some political
narrative and so what they're saying is
there's fake news that we're attaching
our jokes to so we're promoting fake
news with satire that's like writing on
the top of that does that make sense
whereas the onion or left-wing comics
are rooted in reality and and i feel
like it's exactly the opposite like and
the validation of that is the fact that
our jokes constantly come true you know
we make these jokes and they come true
it's like well there's a reason they
come true it's because we were we were
on we were on to something there was a
point to the joke that we were making
and reality just caught up to us yeah
sometimes within a matter of hours the
onions jokes don't come true as often as
our jokes their jokes aren't as attached
to reality as ours are honestly the
onion had two really really good jokes
in the past few years one was presidency
already aging joe biden 10 years and it
showed a rotted corpse yeah like that
was good and then the other one was uh
this was back in like 2019 or 2020 and
it said naked andrew yang appears from
time portal to warn us about you know ai
in the future or whatever like that was
also pretty good there was so and this
is something i've experienced before too
with just like cracking a joke about
something and it turns out to be true a
few years down the line because these
people are generally pretty predictable
but there was a really great babylon b
article i want to highlight public
school student can't read but is already
racist at a 12th grade level i thought
like that's hilarious that's a good joke
and i just i don't understand how
someone can read that like that's
clearly fake news disguised as a
punchline it's like no that is very
obviously a joke and so a while ago as
i'm sure you know and i've brought it up
on the show a number of times
snopes did an extremely
pseudo-scientific analysis of babylon b
articles where they literally they
rewrote the headlines to remove the joke
right make it sound like it was an
actual story and then asked people do
you think that this is an actual story
and then based on the number of people
who said yes
they totaled them as people who thought
the original babylon bee headline was a
true story so they said of course we
have to fact check satire nobody
highlighted that study they didn't
conduct this oh they didn't conduct that
was done at some university and then
they republished it
so the findings but they didn't just
rewrite our headlines they literally
reworded them so they didn't sound like
jokes anymore no they took the jokes out
yeah they took the joke out stripped it
of its like comedic you know structure
yes and removed the image and the image
is usually like a silly photoshop you
know like a
fake looking photoshop or a ridiculous
outlandish image they take that away too
and just present you with this like
you know headline that maybe it could be
true i don't know but it certainly
doesn't sound like a joke so one
one example um oh sorry so so one
example
was you guys did a bit that was like uh
it's it's with a picture of some news
anchor and it says
god allowed the mueller report to test
our unshakeable faith in collusion
and they reworded it as cnn news anchor
anderson cooper said his belief that
trump colluded with russia is unshakable
uh
uh it will not change regardless of
statement or evidence to the contract
that is a completely different different
sentence yeah and so to ask people if
one sounds true and then when they
answer that it does sound true to apply
it to the first statement it's just
totally dishonest how do you i have
issues with satire and that i'm
concerned when people don't know it's
satire how do you like how do you manage
that
with people not knowing it yeah because
if some article comes up and you don't
know ahead of time like this is a satire
newspaper and which is a lot of times
why they ask you to put satire on the s
do they like with your descriptions in
like your twitter or like any other i
mean they can
it's labeled satire in the sense that if
you actually click on our website you
know like our tagline is fake news you
can trust and like you know our about us
page is obviously a joke but we don't
put on every article this is satire and
then close the article with what you
just read with satire you know we're not
just it kind of kills the joke to be
constantly reminding people this is a
joke so you can't do that really yeah so
you have to just present it and people
either get it or they don't and a lot of
people don't well i want to point out
real quick you mentioned selection bias
for the onion so i pulled up the wayback
machine and i looked at a few 10 year
old archival posts and like yeah they're
not particularly funny to be honest um
there's a few ones and i think there's
something interesting i see here because
some of these do make me want to chuckle
super bowl veterans much more prepared
for big games unique stresses rookies
often rattled by pools of boiling blood
scything blades psychosexual
hallucinations like okay
that one's at least a little edgy and it
gave me a chuckle and you look at the
modern stuff now and it's kind of just
like hey you know like there's one
that's like kill your dad and it's like
a woman like waving something at her dad
i'm like doing comedy now you're
tiptoeing through a minefield comedians
are literally getting attacked on stage
chappelle's attack
you know like other people there's you
know there's stories about that there
was just one in the new york post a few
a couple of weeks ago you know about how
it's not just you've heard about a lot
of these cases but there's cases
happening at smaller comedy clubs too
where comedians are feeling like they
need armed security to go on stage and
make jokes because they're going to
offend somebody who's going to get
violent
or the right to keep and bear arms
right and defend themselves right yeah
you mentioned this
term that snopes uses which is labeled
satire which i just also want to
highlight
there's something a little bit sneaky
there like this isn't obviously satire
it's labeled satire but it's still like
it leaves the question of whether you
guys intend it to be satire or not
that's intentional that's intentional
like a news organization that's masked
as a satire organization well because
their position is and they haven't
changed that their position is that we
are claiming to be a satire site so that
we can mislead people yeah how does that
even make sense it was it's a claim new
york times described us as a far-right
misinformation site that sometimes
traffic some misinformation under the
guise of satire wow so like a comedian
that'd be like
that's a long way of saying it's a
comedian right
under the guise of satire though you
know we're putting it on we're wearing
the costume we're we're claiming we're
satire but it says satire on the website
it says fake news at the top of the
website well and also like like he said
that you know the the pictures that go
along with the articles are clearly
photoshopped a lot of context clues yeah
usually like a setup punchline formula
in the headline like if people are are
not discerning enough to understand the
difference between reality and fantasy
it's not
my fault i can't i can't well lower the
bar
theory it's not the internet it's the
people yeah there's a big difference
between you know a fake news site and
this is what they're trying to lump us
in with you know you'll see a fake news
site that pops up and they want to get
clicks they do a story about how kevin
hart dies in car accident and that's the
headline kevin hart dies tragically in
car accident well it didn't happen and
that's not a joke it's not funny they're
just making up a fake headline it's a
lie and it's a lie that gets clicks
because people are like oh my god did
kevin hart die and then they share it
so you know when we write a joke you
know that's not what we're we're not
just trying to like throw something out
there that might get clicks there's a
point there's a punch line you know
there's a and the whole thing ties
together the headline the image
everything it all ties together so
you're never going to be able to get a
hundred percent of your audience to
understand that you're doing satirical
jokes
you don't remember the legendary babylon
b article kevin hart died yeah it was it
was huge it went viral it was tragic
kevin hart dies in car accident that's
our best headline yeah uh did you guys
get banned off twitter did babylon b get
banned off twitter there was uh some
drama about it a couple months ago or
something babylon b
uh did a joke well so the usa today
named rachel levine woman of the year oh
right and uh and babylon b responded to
that we did a joke about how rachel
levine had been picked as our man of the
year
and uh and twitter didn't like that very
much so yeah we got uh we got reported
for hateful conduct and we were told to
delete the tweet wow um and basically
instead of them just taking it down
which you know to my thinking if they
have a problem with this tweet they can
take it down they don't have to force me
to like bend the knee and admit that i
did something wrong but they want us to
say that we engaged in hateful conduct
and acknowledge that and delete the
tweet and take it down and so what we've
done we've been in twitter jail for
three months because we've refused to oh
awesome but as soon as elon
makes that purchase
as soon as elon makes that purchase
we'll see i mean we're he's given us no
assurances but i would expect that that
if he does go through if the deal does
go through when elon musk takes over
twitter then i would expect it so
situations like ours would be corrected
well we'll see i pulled up the onion
from september 13th 2001 yeah that's
what i'm going way back now that's when
i was reading it this one actually i
kind of think it's funny guy's gone wild
and it's a fat dude pulling his shirt up
with stars over his nipples
other than that it is it is not
particularly funny that sucker jesus has
forgiven me for some pretty bad sins
yeah that's pretty great like and then
this article right here it's just like
congressman admits to sexual
relationship that doesn't even sound
like satire right yeah that's just like
not at this point i don't even know if
it is to be honest they were literally
just saying gordon graham admits to an
affair it's like okay it's kind of like
have you guys been parodying putin much
these days like stuff putin's up to and
putin like eating ice cream and all that
crap mostly biden not something
yeah that i got one here from the onion
in 2001 starving bandage bin laden
offers u.s one last chance to surrender
and i mean that was to me it was like
crying and i was working at ground zero
at that period of my life like smelling
the the wreckage whatever was the bodies
or the
and it was still hilarious hilarious
because it wasn't hateful i mean they're
not doing it to hurt people right it's
like you gotta you gotta enjoy life even
the chaos and soldiers will tell you
that too in the middle of the heat of
the battle you still gotta you gotta
find humor in like some of the craziest
stuff
i guess it's because it's lacking the
argument is that it's lacking context
when it's just like a post with no
i don't know what is it on twitter
there's like no picture verb but if so
if that were the case then why wouldn't
they conduct an actual reasonable
scientifically done analysis of the
headlines as they're actually written
rather than butchering them and then
claiming that because i think i just got
to point out real quick um
i had to frantically click away from the
onion because back in 2000 they had a
racial slur on their front page for like
four days as part of one of their
realities yeah they shut the [ __ ] up
maybe they were a bit more edgy back
then i don't know i was like oh we can't
show that it was the wild west for
better or worse i do think i don't think
that it's bad these days like i don't
people call it a dystopian stuff i just
think it's always been this crazy and
now the the curtains been pulled back
and we can see the inner workings of the
beast
i think that when they are accusing you
of basically hollowing this out and
using it as a skin suit all they're
doing is projecting because this is what
we see them doing with every single
institution they touch that's all they
ever do and they're talking about how
you're like conveying a political
message but trying to do it with comedy
they're trying and failing to do this
with people like colbert and the onion
they're doing it incredibly poorly
because they have no self-reflection
they have no humility they can never be
wrong and those are things that are
required you need to be able to make fun
of yourself because you know if you make
fun of yourself you'll never run out of
material they cannot do it but they're
trying i think they're really jealous of
what you're doing at the babylon bee
that's kind of awesome well i think you
undermine them yeah they did they'd
actually make fun of us a little bit
they were kind of like without naming us
you know they were they were making
jokes about how they'd been suspended on
twitter and this is their last tweet you
know like or they they can no longer
tweet and they're tweeting that you know
so they were kind of ironically like
tweet what's the joke the joke was that
we were i guess like
putting it on that we were being
suppressed or but we still are on
twitter and we can still tweet if we
want to or something like that the joke
was that we're faking it i don't know
it wasn't really abundantly clear it
wasn't abundantly clear and no one got
it because no one knew what they were
referring to exactly their audience has
no familiarity with what's going on with
us right and twitter so it's just kind
of like it got no engagement no reaction
yeah well and so lydia you made a really
good point about projection and this is
something i kind of want to talk about
for a moment here when
i write a joke
or someone pitches a joke to me for
freedom tunes or i write a rough concept
that i want to shop around to friends
nobody goes i like the political point
you're making you should make that one
it's like if they'll either go i don't
like that wonder oh that's funny you
should do it right so people will still
discern whether something is funny or
not even if they agree with it
politically and i know i've spoken with
people at babylon b who have told me
that you know the headlines will get
shot down all the time and then you try
to come up with the one that's funniest
and so what they don't realize is when
we're writing jokes we're not sitting
down going how are we going to get them
like how are we going to get the other
side it's just something comes to your
mind that you think is funny and then
you end up producing it but that's not
how they
write their humor no by the way they
think we're doing what they're doing
real quick i just pulled up the babylon
b and the first thing i see is nancy
pelosi recommends avoiding paint at the
pump by becoming a millionaire through
inside
that's really good
and even the left should find that funny
everyone knows nancy pelosi is like that
pelosi's stock tracker january 6th the
musical i need to watch this oh my gosh
yeah did you
oh are you well what i was going to say
is you know the the only really the only
consideration when you're when you're
writing a headline you're pitching a
headline is
is is it funny you know it's not like oh
does it make the point that we want to
make well that's kind of really
secondary too is it funny it's got to be
funny first you got to lead with that
and where they want to get your head
because this is the criticism that we
have is that you know this we've engaged
in hateful conduct with the rachel
levine joke right
they want you thinking to yourself you
know am i making fun of someone who's
beneath me am i punching down at someone
who's marginalized and oppressed well
i'm privileged that person in a very
high position of government yeah the
white male high-ranking government
official am i punching down at that
person right
but that's that's where they want your
head at they want you thinking in those
terms i'm like i'm not
sexist or racist i don't think people
are beneath me like imagine thinking to
yourself imagine thinking to yourself
you know what i shouldn't joke about
those people where they're beneath me
yeah it's so condescending like we
should be able to joke about each other
indiscriminately right so so you know
having to put your head in that space i
think is really unhealthy but that's
where their comedy writers are at
they're like oh i'm a white male with
privilege writing jokes i've got to be
very careful about all the people i
could be punching down yeah i can't
stand it we're working on a video game
and in the video game characters can be
randomly generated as any race and
there's going to be a character
customization menu so we made the joke
like if we made an anti-racist mode that
took all of the left's ideology and
applied it to the racialization of the
characters in this game like it really
helps you understand just how racist
they are yeah like what their view of
the of people's race was applied to a
video game actually quantified the game
would be banned the game would be found
instantly because you'd feel like it'd
be racist well the idea is like if we
removed the stereotypes or inverted them
it exposes just how racist they really
are like the idea that white people are
privileged and have all these special
benefits if you actually enacted that in
the game then characters based on the cu
the race you choose for your character
would have different stats right away
it's already like right they jump higher
not jump higher i'm not going to get
into how awfully racist it would be but
we could not apply anti-racism to the
game because it's equally as racist as
being
just typically stereotypically racist
right and they want you to think of the
world in those terms when you're writing
jokes it's like well you know can't
can't joke about women women are beneath
me they're beneath me on the power
structure because i'm a man it's like
come on thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there